au bord de la loue cette carcasse
métallique ne paye pas de mine
pourtant la route du moulin chaalis
boichard a une valeur inestimable pour
le patrimoine d'ornans ce week end une
exposition est consacrée à son histoire
les voit toujours comme ça là à l'arrêt
à peu pour houllier intéressant de voir
comment c'était avant de mulas et c'est
déjà pour moi c'est la vie des gens
parce que c'est là qu'on venait moudre
le blé
donc c'est la base le blé c'était la
base de l'avis de tous ces paysans ici
qui avait une vie très dure cette roue
et la dernière de ce type dans la
commune de renom
construite en 1821 elle dispose du
système piguet mis au point par un
meunier du même nom avec les moulins
traditionnels soit y avait pas assez
d'eau soit y en avait trop et lui il va
inventer ce bout là pendant qui va
permettre de régler la hauteur de la
loue en fonction du débit et du hot le
la hauteur de la rivière
aujourd'hui la roue est fragile et
rouillée alors pour la sauver
l'association du pays d'ornans et les
propriétaires de la ruhr recherche des
aides financières
un moyen aussi de faire perdurer cette
histoire de famille qui dure depuis
quatre générations
alors que mon père
avait c'est un projet qui lui tenait
tellement à coeur qu'il avait mis qui
s'est également penché sur
projet et c'était une énergie folle à
dépenser
tous au lycée rendu compte que ce n'est
pas possible de le faire
donc aujourd'hui re met en valeur ce
projet pour moi c'est rapport à mes
parents déjà c'est très important
le projet de rénovation est en cours la
propriétaire rêve même que sa fameuse
roue puisse produire de l'électricité un
jour histoire de rester dans l'air du
temps